I've been up against some of the most
hardcore people out there as you know
the best thing you can do is give
somebody a dose of reality and don't
expect them to change right away I've
been to a Bernie Sanders rally and had a
discussion with a college student you're
in his last presidential run and by the
time I was finished with the
conversation she said you know what the
math doesn't add up I said good they'll
figure it out for yourself I'm David
Webb and welcome to Dave Reubens book
club
something I thought I would never say in
all our years of knowing each other
chapter 7 stop hating straight white men
America and Western values and my guest
today the one and only Dave Rubin our my
her guest
were each other's guests where we are
changing the internet by being civil to
each other even though people want us to
hate each other how about that huh well
they're gonna fail miserably my friend
and as people should now know we've been
friends a long time
and we are aligned but it's after five
o'clock where I am so I'm toasting you
with a Macallan 18 Congrats on the book
I will drink to it and never burn it
right on brother well I can only do
water right now because I got a bunch
more interviews later but
there we go so I want to say that you
were the perfect guy for this chapter we
tried to select people that obviously it
made sense for each one but this idea of
stop hitting straight white men America
and Western values when you and I met
you know many everyone that's read the
book already knows the story I was a
lefty you were on the right we met in
the hall of SiriusXM we struck a
conversation you said hey why don't you
come on to my show we'll debate some
stuff we began doing that we did it
pretty frequently we'd go out for drinks
after go out for dinner and there was no
need to hate anyone but but David Webb
I'm a simple man explained to me how it
is that you don't hate straight white
men it doesn't make sense that's what
I'm told you're supposed to do David
Webb how is it I'll keep it really
simple he takes too much work all right
I know that's kind of a cliche and
people get that but why am I going to
spend time trying to find a way to hate
a guy I meet in a hallway on another
channel which I'm not supposed to agree
with that's a lot of effort how about
hey your name's Dave pretty good I'm a
David let's not get each other can use
and let's just talk about things that
matter that's really how we met I wanted
to talk to someone who didn't share my
particular point of view you were
willing to have that conversation and
here we are many years later good
friends and we're actually two of the
people and I'm going to give a lot of
credit to you because you took a bold
step
you've taken several bold steps Dave
people need to understand you stepped
out and you spoke for freedom useful for
rationale you spoke for getting out of
an age of unreason and go into an age of
reason we've got to get beyond this and
into deeper conversations and that's
what we need to do not just for America
but for the world cuz we set the tone
yeah so I'm glad you brought up America
there because I know that we are both
deeply proud to be Americans and that is
something that that is something that
for some reason the left which used to
be proud to be American seems to now
take deep shame in that and it's like
what what brings us together from for
whatever our
immutable differences are who cares as
an American and yet those ideas seem to
have taken root in a really perverse way
yeah it is perverse and think about what
they've tried to do to you when you're
out in your speak in the canceled
culture we're gonna shut Dave Rubin down
well first of all you and I remember
someone that most people I hope will get
more familiar with if you don't know
them Andrew Breitbart Andrews had more
voices not less Americans have said that
throughout our history even in our most
visceral maybe vitriolic disagreements
but today it's canceled today you don't
get an optic you actually don't get an
opportunity to disagree today and that's
something fundamentally anti-american
and to what other people look at us from
around the world and say I want to be
there because I can do that my friends
my family overseas they love the fact
that Americans can argue with each other
come up with 21 different or maybe more
opinions on something and still realize
that we're Americans can you talk a
little bit about I mentioned three wake
up points in the book and one of them is
about you and I was at the young turks
and we're watching a clip and there's
David Webb and they didn't know I was
friends with you and they're calling you
and Uncle Tom and a sellout and a
self-hating black man and all of those
things can you talk a little bit about
the the slings and arrows that you've
taken because you're pro-american
because you believe in the Constitution
because you believe in freedom I always
tell people when they say I hate the
phrase black conservative you're a
conservative you happen to be black big
damn look I mean I you know you mean
it's not that it has nothing to do with
your identity but you are you are a man
first a human first but can you talk a
little bit about just that it's just
because you're sort of Pro America that
they feel that they can use your
identity against you well you know the
first thing game is I'm sorry you're a
beautiful identity yeah well look the
skin color is obvious right that's the
first thing anybody walking down the
street can see your skin color mine my
skin color therefore it really doesn't
matter what they can see is what's in
our minds and in our hearts
I've had these values since my teen
years and I developed more along with
the learning and education that comes
with growing a little bit older and
learning more things I'm a Republican
you know I'm someone who's proud of the
Constitution proud of the country and
our culture and and that's why I am Who
I am because I'm proud of it so I don't
hate myself ever I get one day I love
myself way too much yeah it's it's just
a crazy situation when you when you just
say hey here
Here I am here's what I believe I love
my country and they want to come for you
for that what do you say about this but
at 17 years old I began a process of
applying to the Naval Academy I was
decided on colleges and yes because of
my family history which goes back to the
Revolution I'm actually a son of the
American Revolution the great great
grandson of a man who led a revolution
in Jamaica slave rebellion I grew up
with that bright I knew who I was so I
raised my right hand I served only a
short time I went to school I make no
bones about that but I wanted to show my
love for the country because of what I
wanted to do also for myself which is
very much a part of what we do in
America you can serve the country you
can serve yourself you can serve your
community it's not just about military
it's about just being a good human being
and we've lost that too much but I'll
tell you I'm gonna shock people I
disagree with the overarching narrative
by the cacophony of frankly overrated
voices who say that America is bad
Millennials are bad boomers are bad all
of this is bad come on you and I travel
the country there are so many good
people in this country I've been in the
deep south I've been in ruther races
I've interviewed this is I interviewed a
member senior member of the Ku Klux Klan
I've been divider Texas and then as so
many parts of this country and I've seen
black white
every others dynamic play out
politically culturally you name it and
you know what I'm still here because
there are more good people in Tupelo
than they would tell you in some parts
of the media
you got you got some tricks on how we
can get people out of this mindset
because the reason I titled the chapter
like this stop hating straight white men
stop hating America is that it seems
like it's just like this easy thing to
catch when you're a young person you
live in this privileged place which I
believe is the only privilege there is
in America is American privilege it's
pretty freakin spectacular but they're
they seem like they're very easy ideas
to catch that make you feel morally good
or something like that
what what kind of success have you had
you know D converting people from that
because it ain't easy no it's not and
I'll tell you I've been up against some
of the most hardcore people out there as
you know the best thing you can do is
give somebody a dose of reality and
don't expect them to change right away
I've been to a Bernie Sanders rally and
had a discussion with a college student
you're in his last presidential run and
by the time I was finished with the
conversation she said you know what the
math doesn't add up I said good they'll
figure it out for yourself
I don't try to convert people I talked
to them I asked them what's important to
them and I think if you engage people by
saying what's important to you in other
words we're going down a highway there's
two cars we're in different lanes we're
going down a highway there's a
destination at the end but we have
different lanes and different approaches
to get into that same destination so
does mine make sense does yours make
sense and if we can figure out that
somewhere in between these two lanes is
a middle lane where we can have the
discussion then maybe we can understand
more about what really matters rather
than focus in on our individual choices
and look I've changed my mind on things
my eyes have been open there were
smarter people than me out there so I
don't try to tell somebody I'm smarter I
just ask them to look look at the issue
for what it is look in the mirror and be
honest with themselves it's what my
father taught me he said if you can look
in the mirror if you can talk to
yourself and say I'm confident I can
back up my facts I'm pretty sure and you
know what last part if somebody brings
you a better set of fact
then son you've got to adjust your
position
one of the things I've been getting
asked a lot while I'm on this book tour
is why is it that people on the right
say conservatives libertarians
old-school liberals seem much more open
to the debate and the discussion than
people on left I I have my own theories
I want to hear yours but before I before
I let you jump in on that one of the
things that I've noticed is every time I
do your show when you throw it to the
caller's almost every single caller says
the same exact thing which is hey
they'll be saying it to either one of us
they'll say Dave or David or both of you
guys I don't agree with you on
everything but I'm happy you're having
this conversation do you think there is
an actual philosophical or psychological
reason that people on the right seem to
be better at that right now than people
on the left yeah I think there is and
the way I put it four years is the
liberal brain versus the conservative
brain not Republican versus Democrat but
this unfortunately has changed and I'm
going to change it now for the very
first time it's no longer liberal brain
versus conservative brain it's leftist
brain versus conservative brain because
liberal ideas are not bad ideas we have
difference you know who you're talking
to my grandma yeah but but you know the
liberal idea of learning more expanding
your horizons caring is no different
than the conservative idea the problem
is leftists have inserted themselves the
anti-american anti-freedom crowd and
frankly they're cowards they're flat-out
cowards because they won't engage in a
debate of ideas with somebody who
disagrees with them back to the canceled
culture if dave rubin decides to step
out and say I'm a gay man I'm a gay
married man and by the way we joked
about this on late-night TV you remember
that
hey David if you had been gay for a day
would
Dave Rubin oh my god he's got a sense of
humor holder black Republicans are
supposed to have a sense of humor these
are people who are fearful and I'm just
Comedy Central let us do that but the
thing is they took the chance looking
for the failure what did you and I do we
proved that we could sit there with
others have a reasonable discussion
about our agreements disagreements and
differences and when it came time we
found out we could actually laugh
together and you know maybe it's an
old-school phrase but laughter is the
best medicine can laugh at yourself
laugh at things and along the way you'll
find that you have more in common yeah
what do you make about the the middle
part of this which is that it's okay we
say straight white men Western values
but I think the part that I didn't put
in the title that I think is the
underlying of all of this is sort of
just the endless attack on Christians
that we see that it's just like that's
like just aloud and I'm not look you I
think you should be able to basically
say whatever you want and all that stuff
that you know my feelings on free speech
but just sort of like the mainstream
like if you mock Christians you are
applauded for it while if you were to
mock any other group you would be lauded
yeah you know what I gotta say that that
one troubles me and there are you know
there are times when I look at it I go
what is your role are you going trying
to shut down this group because they're
Christian are you trying to shut down
somebody because they don't care the
same way you do well the idea of freedom
is that you know I don't have to agree
with you Dave you don't have to agree
with me but we have to respect each
other's rights and this is where you and
I align so perfectly on the constitution
individual rights are not crowd thing or
groupthink individual rights are our
rights we do have limitations on how you
express your right we allow Nazis to
march in Skokie Illinois but at the same
time we don't allow you to go in and
inflame the situation you know the shout
fire in a crowded theater approach so
we've got to walk a careful line but I'm
not afraid and
fortunately too many Americans are
afraid of the disagreement so they come
out and they take it on to let's attack
Christians white you know turn the other
cheek Christians are meek but the same
cowards won't go out and attack Moslems
they won't go out and attack another
religion but they'll pick on Christians
and Jews and maybe Buddhists and others
who won't come back because they don't
fear it well you shouldn't need to fear
it to have a discussion about it it's a
level of cowardice that we need to erase
in this country
are you hopeful that we can reset some
of this stuff I mean people always ask
me if I'm an optimist or a pessimist and
I always say well I'm a world-weary
optimist because I consider myself a
realist first but but I don't think I
could wake up and write a book and do
everything that I do if I if I didn't
believe that what we do can fix some of
this stuff can restore you know pride in
America an understanding of freedom and
liberty and all of those things I
suspect you're ballparking in the same
spot as me on that right I'm not only
the eternal optimist look we all face
challenges there are times when I'm
sitting alone or I'm thinking about
something and it gets me down it does
you know I'm humid I sit there and I
look at it they go how the hell do I
change this person's mind or these these
group of people to think or at least
maybe not change their mind to get them
to think outside themselves and as soon
as I go there I remember basic lessons
this country this culture this Western
value system is founded on laws that are
set in place to protect all men and
women to protect societies and yeah our
Constitution is different than the
British than the Australia and other
countries that are in the western
hemisphere of the globe but for the most
part we value
the chance to be who you are the chance
to debate someone the chance for freedom
and that's when I remember the basic
rules the basic rules are we've got more
in common in this life and if I don't
like someone or disagree with someone
and I'm not pretending that there aren't
really bad people out there we need to
be off off and out of the conversation
but if I vehemently disagree with you I
still think fundamentally we have the
right to live together and exist
together in a society like ours and you
know what that debate actually excites
me and then all of a sudden um out of
that dark place and I'm out of that a
moment when I when I'm so worried that I
become more hopeful and I'm more hopeful
because of guys like you like me we have
a responsibility we have a megaphone and
we have a microphone we have a camera we
have what we're doing here and if we
exercise that responsibility more and
more then there's other people that will
join in with us because we are more than
them and we're going to win this
well I know we should probably end it
there because it was so perfect but I
want to bring up one other moment with
you because it went viral and I know
that most of my audience has heard it
before but it's worth bet it's worth
repeating again because it actually
captures the essence of this chapter
more than anything else can you explain
what happened
in your radio experience with Areva
Martin who is a progressive who I
actually had on the Rubin report way
back when many years ago she happens
she's a perfectly nice lady from my
experiences with her but you were on the
radio with her and something interesting
happened and it gets to the exact
purpose of why I titled this chapter
this so Arriva Marty smart woman Ivy
League education lawyer analyst for CNN
their team reached out and wanted to
come on the show to talk about the
nomination of justice Kavanaugh now
justice Cavanaugh we have the discussion
in short they picked me I even picked
them but because the discussion went to
something which powered it or mirrored
what's supposed to be the you know the
white male dynamic white male
conservative dynamic without any
hesitation it was so easy for her to say
to me David because you're a white male
you have white privilege now think about
that for anybody watching this for a
second I'm gonna guess you know that's
not they're not white cheeks and me we
got him Craig I'm Way high but what she
what she did was so easy and so sad in a
way she not only couldn't do the
research couldn't tackle me on the basis
of ideas me saying I didn't believe that
my color of skin was my primary driver
to shorten it up but that she also had
to go further and throw our team under
the bus so there's a fundamental
dishonesty about her she may be a nice
lady I'm not gonna judge her personal
character I'm not gonna attack her but
she's an ill-informed and in many ways a
willfully ignorant
person who was bound to a description
that has been fed to her or that she has
absorbed into her person and become
someone who judges by a broad stroke and
a false construct it's fascinating yeah
well it's so fascinating because
obviously it was radio not video so she
assumes that you're white by your
thoughts then when you say she threw her
team under the bus her response when you
said well I happen to be a black man her
response was oh my people gave me the
wrong information as if as if any of us
when we go on a show they hand as a
thing and it's like are you talking to a
white guy is 34 he's you know he's
heterosexual bla bla bla but but the
reason I wanted you to mention that
again is it's it's such a perfect
encapsulation of the whole chapter
because her implication was your
thoughts had to be the thoughts of white
men thus they were wrong and then the
second you confront her on the truth she
then throws her own people under the bus
as opposed to rethinking her thoughts
and if I'm not mistaken you did invite
her to chat after that but nothing came
of it is that right my producers reached
out we emailed her team she said on the
show at that time I would come back
because I would give her the microphone
I would give her an hour I wanted her to
come in studio so we could have a
reasonable discussion on this you know
I've been dealing with this my whole
life
and I've watched it get worse so let's
go back to the subtitle of your book and
I by the way I borrowed the subtitle to
write a lot of articles thinking for
yourself in an age of unreason I've
watched an evolution of the wrong voices
getting them a joke getting a big
platform in college my young years the
decade seems to where we are now these
are people who should not have a public
forum not because I want to shut them
down but they don't deserve one they
haven't earned it and the fact that all
my life people told me you shouldn't be
my question is always tell me why I
shouldn't be I didn't see in the books
where black people had to be Democrats
or on the left
and white people especially old white
people had to be Republicans
evangelicals and on the right I saw a
part where this country has a flag that
we pledge our allegiance to then we
raise our right hands for those who
serve in the military but that we all
across this country stand up in respect
as a way that says you know this has a
representation the field of blue the
Stars the blood that was shed so that we
have the opportunity to disagree with
each other this is who we are human
beings disagree they talk they argue
sports religion any topic you and I have
debated so many of them but we never
walk away going I need to take you out
of it and I need to take you out I need
to demean you and attack you and my
audience loves you for that reason they
love because they don't actually see the
difference between us they see more
similar things between humanity it
doesn't matter my friend webb you're the
best I appreciate you doing this and I
look forward to some whiskey and real
life one of these days I suppose just
for you Dave
many of them in the caolan80
here's to you my friend good luck you
don't need it because you're so good at
it and to you the family and your dog
don't burn this right on if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell